foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey you guys oh my god i miss you guys
so much i know it's just me um but
hopefully tom said he was on his way
back i'm not really sure how long he's
gonna be though and i was just like [ __ ]
it i'm just gonna go on by myself
until
he gets his ass back here because
i didn't know he was gonna be gone all
day and i was like we have to do this
that and the other thing and then you
know it's like 4 30 and i'm like uh
where are you dude and he's like i'm
still at the house and i'm the old house
and i'm making all this progress and i
was just kind of like
okay but can you get back here though
because i don't really want to like do
this by myself now if it's
lower resolution or
if it's like buffering and stuff i i'm
bad about that listen to what went on
with this internet you guys okay
so the house we moved to it's not like
like somebody asked me earlier it's like
how rural are we talking about it's not
like i said it's not like deliverance
rural it's not like in the middle of
nowhere we live like in a regular ass
neighborhood it's a neighborhood it's
got like the sign out front i think it's
called black bear reserve or whatever
it's called so there's like a [ __ ] ton
of houses around here but around that
there is just kind of like it's a lot of
farms like horse farms nurseries like
equestrian centers that kind of stuff so
it is kind of rural in that regard
and i didn't realize that when we moved
here
um
i looked up like okay well who's you
know what internet services have you got
and the only one that came up for this
address was centurylink
and so i was like well i guess we're
stuck with that even though it wasn't
super fast and so we signed up for that
and then they come here
and they plug the modem into they're
like oh well they send me the modem it
was like this big [ __ ] it took
him like a week to sort out they sent me
the modem
and then they're like oh this has to go
on a phone jack i'm like is this 1996
what the [ __ ] is going on with this and
it's like we're looking around in the
house it's like do we even have a phone
jack and it's like i'm looking there's
no phone jack upstairs where my office
is the only phone jack in the house
is downstairs in the kitchen and i'm
like so i can't hook up my land cable to
it because it's way far away and i was
just kind of like oh man this is just
not gonna this is not gonna be good
and then they get it but we finally get
it hooked up and then we could never get
the internet to work and then so i call
them and i'm like what the [ __ ] like you
know i can't get it to work and they're
like oh we'll send a technician out but
it's going to be thursday like this
coming thursday and i'm like [ __ ] look
it's like i work online it's like i've
already had like a week where
i couldn't get anything done because i
couldn't get online other than on my
phone and my phone has a data limit and
i'm already over it so i also do not
have high speed on my phone anymore so
i'm like you guys are killing me
so i was just like what are we gonna do
it's like i think this is the only
internet service that is out
here and you know and so finally we're
like looking on the side of the house
and then like on the roof of the house
there's a satellite dish and it says
hughes net on it and tom's like why
don't you call them because obviously
whoever lived here before had that and
maybe that's you know maybe we can
figure that out so finally i was like
well it's not ideal but i guess they
don't have high-speed internet like in
this neighborhood yet but because
they're building houses here maybe
maybe maybe it'll get like did jenny
leave tom in the old house i think he's
on his way here um
you know
there is some lagging yeah i kind of
figured there was it's like it's weird
because on youtube because i have obs
open and i also have youtube open
um on obs it keeps flashing back and
forth from like red to green
which is kind of like oh you know it
keeps going back you know because i had
to turn down uh the kilobytes per second
i had to turn down the resolution and
stuff like that just uh you know to make
sure that i could actually stream
but
on youtube it says excellent connection
so i don't know what the [ __ ] is up with
that i'm just like
we're doing we were gonna do a test
stream yesterday but we were just busy
and we never got around to it
so you know but hopefully tom said he
was on his way back so i'm not really
sure he had to
um
he had to go back to the old house he's
had to go back to the old house to clean
and like fix stuff because what ended up
happening was that
even though like it's cool that the
landlord's like hey let's switch houses
because you know i think we mentioned on
the last one but
um but the the guy can't like walk
upstairs anymore and this is a two-story
house so he's like well we want to move
into your house because your house is
only one story so i was just like okay
well that's fine so then like we moved
out here and then they were like
initially they said well you can have
two months uh but then suddenly they
were like oh yeah no never mind you only
have like two weeks so we were kind of
like well [ __ ] so we started like
packing all the stuff up and then it's
weird that they told us before like
before we even moved in there like 10
years ago
that they said oh well it's okay if you
guys you know want to paint or if you
guys do whatever um so we painted some
rooms and then and now that they're like
moving back into it and they have to
paint over it now they're like flipping
out about it they're just like oh my god
now we have to paint over this that i
was like yeah but you said it was okay
and they've been to the house like lots
of times and they've seen it so it's not
like it's a new
thing but you know so tom's been going
back over there and trying to take some
of the paint off the cabinets and like
you know fixing some of the walls where
we put like the
little cat entertainment center up i
guess it was some holes in the walls
that were mad about that so he's been
like going back and forth like fixing
all this [ __ ] up and he's super super
stressed out and so he's been there
since like god when did he leave like 9
or 10 this morning he went i was still
on my exercise but he went over there
and i didn't like i said i didn't
realize he was gonna be there like all
day long um he was just asking me
because we had to do another thing we
had to do too was that we were um you
know absolution fest in tampa like that
big goth like three day goth festival is
this weekend it actually starts tomorrow
um and we were doing the shirts for them
and so tonight after this
we got most of the shirts printed but
then they wanted some tank tops and the
tank tops were delayed coming from
california so i'm still waiting for ups
to bring the tank tops there's only 17
of them and then we can print them and
then we have to go
down to uh orlando like altmont springs
and we have to like drop off the shirts
so they can take them back to tampa and
like sell them at the festival tomorrow
so
i've been really stressed out today i've
been like kind of i'm just sitting here
going we got to do this we got to do
that and then like i'm waiting for the
ups truck wear those shirts so i can
like print them real quick so we can
take them down to starbucks and hand
them off to the to them and it's like
then i'm like when is tom coming back
because i didn't know that he was going
to be gone all day so i was just kind of
like oh my god it's been like a really
stressful week you guys
uh but yeah uh philbert said that sucks
they pulled that on you yeah that's kind
of like and it's it sucks because
they're like really nice people and like
i said we've lived there for like 10
years and you know we knew them
and
they really they didn't get upset about
stuff until like i said until they
wanted to move into the house and then
they were like oh we have to change this
and the other thing we have to paint
over
you know this room because they don't
like the color or whatever um but you
know i don't know it's i was just mad
because i was like look you know you
told me it was okay so
we did and you've seen it you said it
you know you you weren't bothered about
it at the time so don't
don't come out and be like mad about it
now you know what i mean and it's just
you know and they were mad because we
hadn't finished cleaning the house yet
and they're just like you know we want
the keys they wanted to move in and i
was just kind of like well we still have
to go back and like vacuum and mop and
all this other kind of stuff because it
took us so long to get all our [ __ ] out
of the house because we've been there
for 10 years you know what i mean so
there was a bunch of crap there and we
hadn't finished cleaning and they were
mad about that and i was just kind of
like holy crap so
you know tom is on the way there sounds
like a big house uh yeah it is
he's hopefully he comes back soon he's
like um
tom of the legs
was that about the facebook thing that
he posted with his cabs i didn't see the
video i just kind of saw that he'd
posted it and i saw a couple of our
friends like commenting on it
i just thought that was really funny but
yeah um somebody mentioned the suspiria
poster in the back i know it's like i
love that [ __ ] poster so much it's
like obviously i love the original
suspiria like more than the remake like
but i really liked the remake too and
honestly like that poster when i saw
that i was like i just have to have that
honestly there's um
i don't know it's i don't think they're
available on amazon anymore i put them
like my wish list a long time ago but i
don't think they're available
somebody like some artist i can't
remember who it is but they made um
sort of like i don't think they're huge
i think they're only like 12 by 18. but
they made like their own
uh suspiria posters and they are
gorgeous like a lot of them are like art
nouveau kind of looking which i love
which my whole bathroom is like
and um
you know so i wanted some of those but
when i went to get them they were not
available anymore which made me really
sad thank you zack congrats on the house
office looks great thank you gonna miss
the show because i'm gonna see no time
to die in a few hours great to see you
streaming again too
yay thank you yeah um yeah tom wants to
see no time to die also which i want to
find i don't even know where the closest
movie theater is to here uh i think
you know what's sad
i think i looked it up and i think the
closest movie theater to us was the same
movie theater that we were going to at
the old house even though this is like
15 or 20 minutes away
um like i said this isn't rural rural
there is some stuff like oh thank you
victor oh my gosh thank you so much
happy birthday thank you very much thank
you very much i had kind of a you know
kind of a nothing birthday because it
was just kind of like i mean i streamed
with you guys and that was fun but other
than that we were like so stressed out
like from moving and all the crap we had
to do because my birthday fell on the
sunday and then monday was like big
moving day that was like we that was the
day we had the big massive u-haul and
you know
the guys like the three guys that took
all the furniture like over the house
and stuff like that so it was kind of
like
sunday we were just kind of like well
we'll just go out to lunch and
do a stream and then we'll just rest
because we have like all this kind of
crap i gotta do
but uh yeah how are pookie and beijing
doing oh i wanted to say
so we brought the cats over
uh we brought most of their stuff except
for the tree like the cat tree we bought
we brought that like toward the end
because it's kind of big and we had to
like uh we had to like disassemble it
and then we brought it back and i was
kind of sad because it was at the old
house for a long time and i kept saying
to tom it's like bring the tree bring
the trees like it doesn't fit in the car
it doesn't fit the car it does but you
have to take it apart
and then we brought it back and we put
it together like in the upstairs living
room and pookie doesn't even give a [ __ ]
about it i sprayed catnip on it and
everything i was like but that's your
favorite you
you loved it so pookie was freaked out
by the stairs like we brought her in
and she stayed uh her in beijing we had
them in the carriers like in the car we
had a bunch of other [ __ ] in the car too
but it was mostly like pillows and
blankets and stuff because i was like i
don't want anything falling on them
because beijing was in the carrier in
the back seat and i was carrying a
pookie like in the front seat because
she does not like to ride in the car
she's only been in the car like two or
three times and every single time was to
go to the vet and so she does not
deal well with it she doesn't freak out
but
the whole time like the whole 20-25
minute drive to the house she was crying
like the whole time she was like
she was like looking out with her big
ass eyes like looking at tom driving she
was like what the [ __ ] what is going on
so we brought her to the new house she
had to stay in the carrier
they stayed in the carriers for a little
while while we were like unloading the
car and everything so they wouldn't like
run into the garage or run outside or
anything because i don't want them
running outside like and they're not oh
i just heard tom's voice because they
weren't familiar
because man i was [ __ ] up
you were [ __ ] up
i was telling them about uh about pookie
and how she cried all the way here i was
beijing beijing fought like hell to get
into the cat carrier but once she was in
the car she chilled out and she got
quiet you guys were getting my messages
uh dude when i was roaming i was in oh
okay i'm in the house
people are saying it's lagging a little
bit but um other than that it's okay see
because i'm going like from red to green
but it's uh on on my uh
this is this is my uh roaming oh okay
okay so i'm not on that i'm not on the
uh the wi-fi
okay and roman and i was dr as i was
driving i was looking down at it and it
looked like [ __ ]
but the audio doesn't seem to be bad
that's what everybody said everybody
said the audio was okay right
but uh no the picture you can see oh
[ __ ] well well you [ __ ] it up well i
yeah i i knew that it was going to be
like a little laggy like i turned down
some of the [ __ ] but i'll i'll [ __ ] with
the settings this is like i said this is
kind of like a test
i've been sitting here for a [ __ ]
damn five minutes already and i'm still
not in a damn picture so they're [ __ ]
late
the the the comments are gonna be all
[ __ ] up no
oh look
what
well this might be my roaming but my uh
uh live chat stopped oh interesting
mine's still going
yeah i'm kind of it's you know i think
victor told me earlier
that maybe we should look into like
wi-fi hotspots like for at t or
something like that but i'll look into
it because
you know like i said i don't want to
necessarily rely on this was we kind of
got this because we had centurylink at
first and that was like not working at
all man i got this damn microphone right
in my [ __ ] way well we didn't have um
i haven't installed the arm yet yeah
because i didn't really know where i was
gonna put it okay so we gotta figure it
up here above us somehow yeah well i
don't i don't know if it's going to like
hold on that so we'll just have to
figure out i have to figure out what i'm
going to do with that like um with that
on air scientist time i was still
working at the old house yeah yeah i was
talking all about man i [ __ ] i
[ __ ] painted some [ __ ] i shouldn't
have
i painted the damn kit the kitchen the
bathroom the bathroom cabinet it's black
well you know that's what we do
my landlord [ __ ] freaked out she
didn't know
but it was uh
latex enamel yeah or excuse me latex
over spray enamel clear coat so most of
it just pulled off like it was
plasti-dip but there were a couple areas
in there and cup
like the fronts and everything it took
it took some scrubbing to get it off um
it's gonna be all right it's just
[ __ ] labor intensive [ __ ]
wearing me out [ __ ] up my mantosterol
your mantosterol yeah
holy [ __ ]
now i'm trying to get back on on on um
this is my roaming that's having
problems now yeah well like i said we'll
i know this is probably gonna be like
glitchy and i was kind of expecting that
but
i just wanted to see i mean it hasn't
kicked me off yet it hasn't stopped like
my obs hasn't stopped so that's
something um
cesspi says the office looks so much
bigger than your previous one yeah the
rooms are way bigger in this house i
couldn't believe it actually when i put
all the desks in here and the
bookshelves and stuff i was like holy
crap like look at all of this
room like in the middle of the room it's
like super weird oh but what i was
saying when you came in was that
we brought pookie in and beijing and
they stayed in their carriers while we
were unloading the cars because like i
said pookie had cried all the way to the
house just the whole entire time
and uh so she comes in and she's like
sitting there going what the [ __ ] and
then we let her out and she's like going
around downstairs like smelling
everything she's like what the [ __ ] is
going on and then tom like picks her up
and brings her upstairs and she was like
what the [ __ ] she'd never been she'd
never been in a house with upstairs
before so she was just kind of like what
the hell is going on with this damn you
just get a 50 super chat i did like a
while back from victory yeah from victor
yeah
it was birthday yeah yeah
um
you know and so
so we were kind of like she was like she
came to like the edge of the st stairs
and she was like looking down like well
how does this work
and so i was kind of like well i'm just
gonna let her
kind of figure it out on her own
and then a couple hours later i came
back i came out or it was like a couple
hours later it was the next morning
and she had actually she ran down the
she went
like down to the first landing and then
she looked up at me because i was like
looking over at her like that she looks
up at me and she goes wow and i was like
yeah the stairs and it was i was like
you did it all by herself
so she figured it out so now she goes up
and down now she's got like her little
red mousy and she and she puts it in her
mouth and runs up and down the stairs
did tanks show up
not yet but like i said there it's ups
um they said it should be here before
seven okay yeah we're doing i i told
them we're doing the shirts for
absolution fest most of them are done
like all the regular shirts are done
and yeah i already told them that if the
tanks don't come in i mean they should
it's only 17 of them we just have to
practice on them man they gave me two
they gave us two weeks to execute that
huge [ __ ] order man and no and it was
the same two weeks where we were moving
yeah right in the middle
there's no way there's no room for error
if there's any problem you just got to
run with it
because there's no time to fix anything
i mean they all came out good though
they all came out good i would have i
would have tried a different dot matrix
on that moon
that could
if the dots are a different size it
would have flowed more consistency but
it's still it's a moon
yeah yeah i i think it came out good
actually
we we printed some for ourselves tom
looks stressed out yet i am [ __ ]
stressed out man although you're less
stressed out than you were last night
because i now that i know that latex is
going to come off there easily yeah i'm
pretty sure he was really worried about
that pretty sure it would but uh i
wasn't sure how i was going to do it
somebody said grandpa says that's
lagging like it's 2002. yeah yeah well
you know like i said what are we going
to do
derma says the audio is perfect though
yeah that's what everybody said
which you know
whatever well like i said we'll figure
it out
my roaming has it has it as loading but
you know what's funny is that
the graphics aren't that bad what do you
have it on
i have it on uh because i looked up i
said what are the best settings for obs
for like um you know a slow internet
connection yeah and they said put it on
720p put it on 30 frames per second no
and put it on 1500
uh kbp way too strong
so i can turn it down farther turn it
way down i mean i might turn it down to
like [ __ ] can you turn it down now no
i'm not in the middle of it but
well i can do it for the next one this
is just a side track show chill out yeah
get a drink tom says sandra no i can't
drink because i'll have to work and then
i have to drive i got to deliver oh
that's yeah that's right i'm having one
but i'm just having one the um uh camp
guy said mine's not lagging much
because i'm looking at it and i'm like
man that's pretty that's pretty hd
that's pretty
in my room yeah i can actually turn it
down to uh i could turn it down to 360.
yeah so we'd be like blurry it'll make
us look pretty yeah
360. well i will for the next
one see here's the thing that
i'm already
don't like this
this satellite [ __ ] because it was
deceptive
they said that they offered three
megabytes per second upload speed i
tested it on my xbox because my xbox can
go
can get on it and test the connection
speed is
one megabyte per second it's not three
it has been taking me a little bit
longer to upload youtube it's a lot
slower it's three it's it's one-third
the speed that they claimed and they
knew
what we were going to do with this
account
so really they said oh no problem it's
actually a violation
that's kind of like uh we could pull it
because we sent centurylink back central
central well that wasn't working at all
yeah that was this isn't working as
advertised
well like i said out here there's not
really a lot of choice i think there is
i'm going to hit up these neighbors and
see how they're yeah they probably
should go over to that house with the
pool yeah
and ask
i already met one of our neighbors her
name was beverly because she got she got
some of my uh packages yeah so she came
i was in here painting like by myself
one day and i look out the window and i
see this car pull into the drive and
this woman's like waving at me because i
was painting over the window and i'm
like who the hell is that yeah and i
toddled down the stairs and she's like
she's like hi i'm your neighbor and it's
just kind of like
yeah i got a bunch of your packages and
i just live right over there she has she
was super super nice she said our our
neighbor's jamaican yeah and i i quickly
forgot about it then i was out there
throwing out a bunch of garbage in the
middle of the night and there's a car up
the road because the houses are far
apart here i don't know
yeah i like that we should take video of
it yeah it's real nice here it's like
the old place it's just more spaced out
yeah the houses are way farther apart
which is nice because our old
neighborhood it was a super nice
neighborhood but all the houses were
kind of close together so
i see a car parked with somebody yelling
and i'm listening man and it was a
jamaican accent so strong i was
expecting [ __ ] reggae music to start
[ __ ]
i was ready for [ __ ] i was ready for
[ __ ] bob marley to start his [ __ ]
singing
sound it sounded like dancehall you know
man
it's all getting ready i thought it was
the dj for dancing go ahead you gonna
come in doesn't matter pokey pokey's
like what the [ __ ] is it she's like why
is this door closed so you're talking to
the lights again yeah
we're talking to the lights what's up
pookie
you like your new house oh she seems to
like it yeah yeah you we should have
turned the graphics all pretty pretty
much all the way down well i will for
the next one like i said you're in cow
country it's actually horse country
horses it's horses and uh nurseries yeah
just pretty much
a mile and a half up the road is a
gigantic
horse
barn and race track and and training
equestrian training facility it's kind
of like the damn daytona international
speedway of horses i forgot the name of
the goddamn thing yeah what the hell is
the name of that place they lease it out
it's it's mostly empty all year round
the guy that owns it well no i don't say
all year round it's mostly empty but
then like four or five events per year
it's just [ __ ] packed
and you know
trailers and [ __ ]
million dollar [ __ ] horses and [ __ ]
[ __ ] show up there all the time and
yeah there's like there's horse stuff
like everywhere this is like where all
the equestrian centers
yeah don't we live like right by not
tiger king but
like a guy like tiger king's friends one
of tiger king's friends or friends or
some somebody else in the exotic animals
yeah he's just up the block but the
thing is is that he is uh
like respectable he's yeah he's not like
no yeah he's not like he's respectable
he's got
[ __ ] he's totally uh you know above
board borders or as above board as
though as big cat he's got a massive
compound yeah and it's got fun he's got
a couple of [ __ ] like lowland
gorillas and some [ __ ] giraffes and
[ __ ] too and i think maybe an elephant
or a couple he's got an elephant in
there i think he's got a couple of i
wouldn't i have to ask it's a big place
and he's got like big like walls like in
stuff around he deals in the in cats
lions and tigers um but he has his own
private collection too it's like a zoo
in there but it's not open to the public
but then again it's that same deal where
you got a dude he's probably in his 60s
by now
with like a young wife in their 30s and
then [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] ton of girls in their [ __ ] 20s
working for him
who knows what's going on in there oh
i'm sure because they gotta imagine the
whole exotic animal [ __ ] cults and
[ __ ] you know but he's evidently uh
legally he's looking he's never in any
trouble he's not like any of the
lowlifes
right
um and then uh yeah there's gonna be
some good video i'm gonna come up with
are we like if we're lagging tell me in
terms of audio if the audio's lagging go
ahead and [ __ ] drop a comment but uh
another up the road about two three
miles i found a new hangout stopped in
there and it's a [ __ ] i'm gonna cut
some videos in there [ __ ] i
planted my flag in the local biker bar
this was built in the 40s it's a little
bitty dive
yeah you got to have a [ __ ]
american-made motorcycle to park in
there so i parked my buell and went in
there and [ __ ] showed up like a
goddamn warrior king all right
day drinking too we were in there during
day
i met some guys [ __ ] some cool dudes
and [ __ ] told them what i do they
looked at the show and they're like oh
man that's pretty cool you know and then
they started asking about [ __ ] all
kinds of different cases what was it
they were asking about nikola tesla
is asking me about nikola tesla that's
pretty awesome yeah
oh yeah they know all about that [ __ ]
there we go they're talking about the
[ __ ] philadelphia experiment they you
know they did we did a show on that
didn't we yeah they were they were all
the old guys you know 60s and 70s bikers
you know that's how old they were yeah
the 60s and 70s they were like where's
where's your where's your harley you
know because they know that a beule is
american-made but where's your harley
are you not interested in something like
that you know i said you got to
understand something man i'm only 52.
i'm not old enough to be on a [ __ ]
heart and they're like yeah you're right
yeah yeah they laughing yeah you're
right
that's old man
around here you see all you see dudes
like middle aged to old dudes on
harley's and like they don't even have
like any helmets on they're just riding
in the like hawaiian shirt and
flip-flops for christ's sake well some
of them are the outlaw biker types too
some of them but you know that's not
much
death metal and [ __ ] i grew up in
daytona beach which is like which is
like biker central yeah uh and we had
two huge events every year we had bike
week that was in spring usually in march
or april and then you had a
biketoberfest and you'd have like half a
million people coming there you'd have
real actual bikers and then you know who
actually rode their bikes there and then
you'd have like your weekend warriors
that brought the bikes on a trailer and
uh just went down there and they were
like touristy bike week actually uh if
you're if you're a local biker around
here and even you know and even say
cyclists too
everybody hates bike week you don't go
to that [ __ ] that's for tourists it is
kind of like because i feel like it
started out as like an actual biker
event but then it got more and more
touristy mainstream yeah the local guys
don't go to that they might go they
might ride through it in a parade type
of deal but they're not they don't hang
out they just make an appearance and
drop their nuts and then they
we showed up [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
but uh outlaw biker types i'd probably
say it's like 1 in 50.
but but that's still there's that means
they're supposed to they live they live
there year round
and hang out at the same bar that yeah
they're hanging out they hang out at
that bar over there too the last chance
the saloon i'm gonna do a video in there
man it's it used to be a gas station
that went across from the main street
cemetery and what the [ __ ] is that is
that last chance now i can't i haven't
been in daytona in so long
yeah well there's also the cabbage patch
oh yeah the cabbage patch yeah yeah yeah
that looks like that's it's so funny
that it's like that has such a
reputation like in there
you go see it it's like a total dump
yeah
that's what this place is yeah well yeah
because we passed it yeah because we
were driving around the other day like
to see what was yeah within distance
yeah you know what i mean it's a total
[ __ ] top but they expect it to be
that way well yeah you're not it's not
the same this guy's not a jump it's got
a stripper pole in there of course it
does let's see some of those old
strippers get up there like old bikers
yeah so yeah
well they're all ages they had some of
the younger ones command cities too they
had some of the younger ones come in too
on hot rod harleys and stuff and [ __ ]
all the girls on [ __ ] hot rodded
sportsters
and uh
but uh you know
you always kind of wonder you know if i
can
some of them guys
you know they're into brand name you
know name brand [ __ ] and they may not
know that the [ __ ] sometimes they
don't know that a buell is an american
motorcycle so you kind of [ __ ] show
up on that you don't know if you're
going to get any [ __ ] for being on a
[ __ ] like that sounds foreign yeah
it's a tricked out looking sport bike
you know what i mean but [ __ ] no they
loved it they loved it they they
recognized what it was so [ __ ] i was
like okay i guess i can hang out here
you're not gonna get picked yeah they
knew it was a custom
grampur's hammer said if tom took
drafting class in high school the
teacher died a couple days ago
did you take drugs no
no no
i took mechanical drawing but that was
in the high school in brazil that i went
to i took drafting at my high school not
that actually no i think i took that in
junior high not high school
what'd you do in polk she used to like
over there yeah she's like yeah she
seems to have adapted to the new house
pretty well yeah yeah you like it
she's been like hanging up family tell
you what i'm gonna get a drink off of
this one okay
it's just it's whipped cream and
whipped cream
yeah
i just made it real quick because i just
because i didn't think you were coming
back so i was just like i sent another
message you see me cussing
no
i was like i'm getting this [ __ ] [ __ ]
way too late you know
showtime's in a half hour
and i said i ain't [ __ ] coming and
then i went back and says all right i'll
go
like don't you swear at me
that [ __ ] better be working because i'm
[ __ ] turning my back on this damn job
and [ __ ] i'm losing time on this it's
my ass if i don't get this [ __ ] done
yeah but i mean we had like a bunch of
other [ __ ] because what happens like
because the shirts are supposed to show
up in the next hour and a half we have
to make those last 17 shirts and then we
have to drive to starbucks in altamonte
springs and drop the shirts off yeah i
got to call him well i got to give i got
to tell him [ __ ] what's got what's up
well i sent him a message earlier
well this morning because he had sent me
a message just like well i have a friend
that's there that can pick the shirts up
because they're in tampa and i was like
well we set it up with sherry right that
we were gonna like drop them off so
somebody's gonna get him
uh tila says jenny i see that tila's in
the comments yeah oh okay see i can't
really my comment section is [ __ ]
jenny i see the suspiria poster in the
background you prefer the new one of the
original oh the original uh big time but
uh i was surprised by how much i liked
the remake i liked that they went like a
totally different direction with it and
honestly i wanted like uh you know i
because i have some other dario argento
posters like right there you can't see
it but i have a profonda russo one the
deep red um
and i i haven't uh i think i've been
opera one somewhere but i don't know
what happened to it it's someplace
around here but i just really really
liked the uh
the design aesthetic of that one
yeah victor says we should change the
intro music yeah i want to change that
music too but we got so much [ __ ] going
on
yeah oh my god my time we need new intro
music we need some new like intro photos
and [ __ ] and you know but we just got to
get around to it man we we're [ __ ]
super [ __ ] busy
yeah and like i said yeah tom ross's
evil clone boobs this welfare connection
sucks hopefully it gets fixed yeah um
like i said if you weren't here at the
beginning uh we've had some problems
with internet providers like out here in
this neighborhood
um hopefully
i'm hoping that in the in coming months
because this neighborhood they're
building new houses yeah like in this
it's not there's a bunch of houses in it
already but apparently this little
pocket here they don't really have any
high-speed internet um
options or none that we know about
couldn't get comcast couldn't get uh or
xfinity or whatever the [ __ ] it's called
couldn't get spectrum
um
pretty much everything that we were
trying to get you couldn't get at this
address
so
we're stuck with satellite at the moment
until we can like find something better
uh so we're gonna like look into that
but we didn't really want to like
leave you guys hanging with no streams
again because i didn't really like that
it had been so long since we'd streamed
and i was kind of like we were kind of
like scared to stream because i said i
know it's probably gonna be like [ __ ]
up and
slow and everything but i don't want to
like not do it better grandfather's
saying it's only a matter of time for
fish and wildlife rage him i don't know
who he's talking about unless you talk
about that animal dealer oh yeah maybe
yeah no they won't raid him he's he he's
legal and licensed he deals with zoos
and all kinds of this this whole area is
based in
animals yeah
buying and selling animals we got cows
out here horses you got exotic animals
it's it's it's been it's been um
that's been the the economy down here
for 5 50 60 years i mean it's it's it's
it's just
and um
now this is also florida
money talks [ __ ] walks
i mean just watch cocaine cowboys
you can get thrown into prison and buy
your way out you still can't
ilsa says you guys should get a tiger
yeah yeah
oh my god look at pookie yeah you can
get thrown in prison sentenced and
sentenced to [ __ ] five years and
[ __ ] go to prison and then they can
go we don't know where that [ __ ] is
that's because you you they just bribed
their way right out the the guards let
them out the [ __ ] cops let them out
[ __ ] if you get pulled over by the
cops hey just let me go man there's a
million dollars worth of [ __ ] coke in
the back just take it and they go okay
this is like central and south america
fair enough you can pass any [ __ ]
laws you want it ain't gonna work they
do whatever they want here it just looks
good on the surface
now if you
it's just like jesus and him
jesus you know [ __ ] around with those
money lenders to me you don't [ __ ] with
them dudes without money if you don't
have money oh no you're going to prison
but if you have money you're not going
away well you know that's kind of like
everything is [ __ ] the poor yeah
only if you're poor
and if florida's pretty honest about it
if you got money you can do whatever you
want
sandra said that must have been the
fastest move ever
from learning that yeah tell us about it
you guys don't understand man i [ __ ]
i can't believe i loaded a lot of those
trucks by myself yeah
two of them two of those loads i hired a
big old [ __ ] truck
with [ __ ] four black dudes one of
them dudes were [ __ ] huge man
we were out there lifting
he's like you got a gym you gotta do
this it's like yeah so after after we
got the move uh we was all four was in
there [ __ ] lifting in the new gym and
[ __ ] because the gym's like right in
there that one dude [ __ ] weighed
weight almost 300 pounds and he didn't
[ __ ]
no it wasn't three probably yeah i guess
it was about 270 i think he was and
there wasn't much fat on that dude at
all he was [ __ ] strong man he was
only about maybe 21 22.
he put
300 pounds
300 pounds is what i put on the bar and
i think he did uh
nine reps of 300 [ __ ] pounds holy
crap yeah not red i heard you guys over
there yeah i didn't know what you guys
were all i heard was
and i said go ahead go for a boy
he did nine reps of 300.
and he goes yeah that'd be good good
work damn you're strong and he said
because yeah you strong for a little man
3d sylvia you're stronger for a little
man yeah
you got to [ __ ] with each other
now you only weigh
580 pounds you know what i mean like in
um 250 weighs a lot to you
grandpa's hammer said did you have a
moving sale no we either brought it or
threw it away
how much did the conan post herself for
we still have it it's not a poster it's
a yeah it's a painting it's going uh if
we're gonna put it in the gym actually
because the gym is gonna have all the uh
the muscle man art work all the [ __ ]
motivations
it's either gonna go there or gonna go
into my [ __ ] my my i might go in my
studio i gotta bring spock in here too
i gotta i've got room in there that i'm
gonna put a workbench in there and maybe
i'll stream from there once we get the
internet
we you can't do that [ __ ] without
[ __ ] high-speed [ __ ] internet
cable and i think it's out there i just
gotta find what these other people are
using yeah go if not it's coming soon
because this whole place they're
building a huge [ __ ]
housing
i don't want to call it project but
housing what do you call it development
housing development it's it's kind of
like the one we just left
all right which is higher density houses
but that same caliber
and somebody who's somebody who is a
listener said to also agreed who she's
in the real estate business he said this
place is going to blow up but they
couldn't give us any details
but they're building these huge [ __ ]
highways freeways out to here so
yeah oh thank you no need for me to hey
everyone glad to see you guys settled in
looking good busy as usual can't stay at
hospital with wife post-op oh
uh hopefully that will go okay all's
well i hope it's going good for you in
the chat as always
uh thank you cheryl stanley oh i missed
you too
yeah if you just got here sorry our
shit's kind of like laggy but you know
our internet connection has been sort of
we lower the nightmare lower those
graphics that'll get better i'll do that
for the next one because like i said um
hopefully
pretty much all they said when i signed
up for the satellite was it's like well
you're not gonna do any like real-time
gaming are you and i was like no i said
but i do a lot of live streaming and
he's like oh it should be fine
um so
i don't know not it not at our
traditional [ __ ] um
you see look
that's pretty good resolution yeah look
how hanging we could actually sacrifice
some of that resolution we also got to
get the light the lighting's right
everybody looks like they have [ __ ]
jowls on this riding in this lighting it
doesn't look that bad yeah it does it
yeah it doesn't look that bad but that's
not ideal well like i said you know we
haven't really had a lot of time to like
get all this [ __ ] sorted out i tried to
like do it by myself but you know yeah i
haven't put up the microphone like on
the arm the arm is still under there
because i haven't figured out
how to do it you know what i mean
yeah um
yeah let's see where's the kublicon
yeah we gotta um we're doing his shirts
for absolution fast if you weren't here
early which is a gothic music festival
in tampa which actually starts tomorrow
uh so we're doing the shirts like last
minute um
but so we have to we have to do like 17
more and then we have to like drive them
to
orlando to deliver them to the people so
they can sell them at the festival i'm
looking good look at that [ __ ] i leaned
out a lot in two weeks i lost at least
five pounds of fat in two weeks i didn't
eat
i mean i think we both lost a lot of
weight because i didn't eat i just we
just weren't eating because we just kept
we kept going back and forth into old
house new house like carrying [ __ ] it's
like so we didn't really some days we
didn't eat hardly anything
yeah i was just kept shooting up
testosterone and [ __ ] taking
performance-enhancing drugs
pretty much
[ __ ] i hadn't eaten today
all i ate was a piece of toast that was
like and that was like um probably like
eight hours ago on some of those days
[ __ ]
on some of those days i was so [ __ ]
jacked up on [ __ ] [ __ ] that was like
an unstoppable locomotive yeah he just
kept going and going just like the
energizer bunny yeah got stronger
stronger stronger just
get more tired i got the more energy i
had
more wore out i was the stronger i got
then to fall asleep wake up [ __ ] like
oh man why did i do that yeah yeah
yeah uh tila says uh jenny halloween
kills comes out next week going to the
theater or are you streaming i wouldn't
mind seeing that in theater actually uh
we still have amc stubs so we can see
and obviously we haven't been to see any
in the last week or two because
you know uh we've had other things going
on but
there's some movement so i'll probably
go to the theater and see it because it
won't cost us anything so why not you
know what i mean
uh yeah mango says great backdrop to the
new studio thank you like i said i have
to bring spock back in here he's in the
living room at the moment we still have
like a bunch of [ __ ] i tried to get like
a decent background going and i was just
kind of like well i can tweak [ __ ] later
on like i said we have to tweak
where the lights are where the [ __ ]
whatever that wasn't the ups truck was
it no i keep i keep listening like out
the window for the ups truck because i
need those [ __ ] shirts so we can uh
get them done
uh
don't overdo it daddy tom and jen yeah
well
there's no choice i had to be done in a
deadline yeah we we had to do it like i
said
it was one of those things where we
thought we were going to have didn't
they initially said two months right
yeah it went two months and then as soon
as i started moving it started this time
oh by the way oh by the way could it be
two weeks yeah and i was like wait a
minute two months or two it's done man
two weeks and then i was like yeah i can
be out of here in two weeks
and then i was out of there in two weeks
but and then they're walking in this
house is [ __ ] up
what are you doing [ __ ] are you gonna
have to put a damn security deposit on
you and i said no i was out in two weeks
the house isn't ready
yeah it's like we're not done yeah we
had to get everything out of here yeah
you know the houses are [ __ ] ready
there's all kind you know i gotta
[ __ ] do sheetrock i gotta [ __ ]
reverse that paint that you didn't want
like i got you [ __ ] i gotta clean the
[ __ ] place what are you talking about
oh yeah yeah well they wanted me to
[ __ ] get the keys no man i got [ __ ] i
got to do your [ __ ] kind of garbage i
had to be thrown out still yeah you know
like busted up furniture that we weren't
taking had that [ __ ] stacked up and he
couldn't put it all out there at once so
they [ __ ] they won't take won't pick
up any of it they're just like [ __ ] that
you put it out there little by little
they'll go okay we'll take that well
yeah as long as it's not like a big yeah
they can't sit there for [ __ ] 20
minutes [ __ ] throwing [ __ ] she's
throwing you yeah you got to put it in a
can or it's got to be like reasonably
well if two men can pick it up they
they'll that's what they told me when i
called yeah we'll see they said if two
men can pick it up
and as long as it's not like excessive i
think you can put like up to three
pieces out there as long as it's like
well i put a couple other pieces out
there too was it three pieces or five
pieces i put some of those boards out
there and i put that glass table top
oh okay well that's it and that old that
old uh
easy curl bar that that you you didn't
that were abandoned because you can use
my easy coral bar okay now that we got
the gym in there that was a sand one
sanded vinyl that's cheap okay i got
cast iron in there
cast iron
saunders said how did beijing react we
only heard about it you [ __ ] love it
yeah beijing like she knows
yeah beijing's moved a couple times
in her life
so she was a lot more chill she got here
and she was just kind of like okay i
suppose so put her in a cat carrier and
driving around at night with the other
cat and all that stuff she was she knew
we were moving when all this stuff
started to leave yeah she didn't want to
get in the cat carrier though
she just was quiet yeah we just put her
in the car she didn't make a peep the
whole time yeah she's like i know what
this is but pookie was in the front seat
going oh my god what's going on
man
the whole whole [ __ ] time
i had the cat carrier this is so she was
like looking out the front like at tom
driving and it was night time
and she's just like look at him with her
big ass eyes and she's like bam yeah
like the whole whole thing i like to go
by and i'd look down and see her and
she's just she's just eyes looking at me
man
and we kept saying it's okay honey it's
okay and she's just like
yeah
the whole entire time it was funny
but she's uh she seems to have like um
uh gotten her gotten her bearings right
she's the stairs kind of freaked her out
at first but after she got used to it
now she's running up and down like a
little buffalo herd
with her little mousy she's having a
good time
uh pookie probably uh thought this is a
long trip long ass trip to the vet yeah
that's probably what she thought because
that's the only time that she's ever
been in the car before wasn't that long
it's only 15 miles
yeah so it was like a 15 20 minute drive
but yeah it was just funny that she kind
of like cried the whole time it's just
like so sad
so sad
so are we back on yeah
so like i said for the next stream if we
stream again on friday night we're going
to stream again on friday night
um i'll turn the resolution down more
so yeah it can it can go down way more
i'd probably keep the frame rate the
same and just lower resolution a bit and
it probably uh
probably would probably go pretty well
yeah i would think because like i said
it hasn't i haven't um had obs like
freeze up on me
even though it's like glitchy on the
other end but it's not because remember
like back at the old house when we were
having trouble with the stream like a
lot of times my obs would freeze too or
my chat would freeze but i haven't had
that happen but it's like apparently on
the on the end it's on the other side no
i got that great i know i got some pair
of military ex-milita ex-police and
ex-military [ __ ] survivalists in the
damn chat
i did research of
hughes net satellite
internet and uh they said that the
upload speed sucks it's the best is
three megabytes per second the download
speeds okay but it'll never
match
high-speed internet cable
okay
oh but what it is good at it would be
like a very good [ __ ] hit the fed
survivalist [ __ ] internet for for uh
anything you know the main [ __ ]
floods and hurricanes and [ __ ] because
it requires almost no infrastructure if
you've got power
you've got internet and honestly it's
not talking to a satellite other than
the streaming other than um this
i haven't had too much trouble like
uploading youtube videos takes
significantly longer
um but i kind of knew that going in now
the only other thing we've had problems
with is watching stuff on amazon prime
yeah i watch stuff like on the smart tv
i watch stuff on shutter i watch stuff
on 2b um i actually watched stuff on
pluto like on my laptop and it was
totally fine no lag no nothing no hd
though
but yeah yeah
but it um for some reason we can't get
amazon prime yeah
to play it's too it's it'll go but then
it like it buffers like every fuse that
might have something to do with what's
going on with facebook and instagram and
all the cyber yeah because all the other
streaming services are working fine um
youtube seems is working fine i watched
a bunch of [ __ ] on youtube today didn't
have a single problem um i watched [ __ ]
on pluto all day no problem uh i watched
a big long thing on shutter no problem
uh it's just amazon prime
it says there's no hard
data walls at our level it's costing us
130 bucks a month for this internet
connection
but you're only like guaranteed i think
it was 50 gigabytes
of [ __ ] data
i think it's 50 gigabytes wasn't it or
was it 500 i can't remember
i thought it was only 50 a month
if you go over that
they slow your rate down they slow your
feed down a little bit i don't know if
that's enough i think that's a lot
it's it's the most that they
offer
so and they say it's for like businesses
and whole families and [ __ ] like that so
it it's got to be pretty decent
victor said i'm telling y'all you got to
get a hot spot modem from at t or
verizon that's all the rural people do
it
yeah it doesn't seem like 18t is
available out here though i don't know
we look for that yeah we'll see how i'm
going to look it up i'll see i'll i'll
look that up because
maybe like i said this is okay
for now
is that a wireless internet modem
is it is it
or is it satellite or something
i have no idea okay i have no idea like
i said i'll look it up i just couldn't
believe
that when i searched
for you know internet service out here
that centurylink was the only thing that
came up
and they're still going through
a modem that plugs into a phone jack
yeah and like i said
what's ridiculous we didn't have we have
one phone jack in this whole entire
house i was like who the [ __ ] has phone
jacks anymore nobody and our old
provider says they don't have it here
and the only reason the only way i found
out about hughes now is because there's
using that dish on the goddamn side of
the house yeah that's the only because
we were like centurylink was taking so
long it was going to take like another
week for them to come out and see what
the [ __ ] was the matter with it because
i was like is the phone line bad or it's
like we don't use land lines obviously
the city first [ __ ] century they
didn't give us any [ __ ] though
about cutting them off they said if they
get that maybe they know that
they know they
get that if they get that that modem
back uh soon
and they're sending us a label then
there's not gonna be any charge okay
that's fine and really uh if there's an
uh an option for hughes net hughes net
should go
well like i said if i can get something
better and faster if we can do something
like a hot spot or something like that
then yeah we'll do that instead
i just had to get something
immediately because i was kind of like
look i can't you know i'd already been
like
i couldn't get internet for like a week
and a half and i work online like all
this is not just this but i you know all
my business is conducted online and i
was like look i can't
all i got's my phone and my phone is
already past the data limit for the
month and it's only like the 6th of
october you know what i mean so i don't
have high speed on my phone either so
for until the end of the month
so i was like i'm kind of [ __ ] i just
kind of need something you know what i
mean uh mandy nicole says i pay like 89
for xfinity high speed a month and i've
never had a problem yeah i looked into
xfinity because xfinity is might be
comcast as well i looked into that but
it's not available at this address
that's why a lot of shit's not available
at this address like i couldn't find
anything and it was like a really and
because the move was so quick yeah we
had a big problem just kind of i was
like okay well we need to get the
internet set up like right away and then
i was like um why is there no like
service there's something out here
because there are [ __ ] high-end
houses all around here and just uh just
up the street you know what you know
when we're going down this okay next
it's [ __ ] funniest things we got a
goddamn dollar general store on the
street i'll take a picture of it you
guys
it's a big one though
anyway across the street from that
dollar general store and on the other
side of the street you know where you
know when i'm turning before we get to
the circle k that road right there on
the right behind that thing that looks
like a forest is not a forest
it's a [ __ ] housing development of
[ __ ] million-dollar multi-million
dollar mcmansions back there oh wow so
they're running something i know you've
got that's what i'm saying
if you confess there's a bunch of rich
ass people living out here and i'm sure
that they don't go without internet they
got internet i don't need to get some of
that rich people internet
so we need to like ask around the
neighborhood like i said
we'll just you know
we just got this because it was kind of
like i needed to get something set up
like immediately and they were fast they
came out and did it like a day or two
later
and
um you know but if it's not gonna be up
to snuff then we're going to like
look for some other options probably
going to buy this house
yeah we've been talking about it and
talking to the vfw
and they're saying oh you want more
money huh you want to buy a house okay
let's say he's going to get back with me
but
so it's a little too early in the game
that's a couple months down the road
before i start talking about that um
seriously i got too much [ __ ] that i got
to set up around here and getting i mean
this is a nice house i don't even know
what it's going to [ __ ] cost to air
condition this [ __ ] i'm kind of
scared like yeah to get the election
it's got two air conditioners two one
for the downstairs and one for the
upstairs two units outside and two units
inside so this [ __ ] costs a lot of
money to [ __ ]
thing is is that you can you can leave
it at 73 or 75 and it still feels pretty
cool because this is a cinderblock house
so it stays pretty cool and actually uh
unusually for florida maybe not so much
um because i feel like back in the back
in the day they'd always do like cinder
block they do a lot of cinder block
houses like one story but usually if
they were doing two story be cinder
block first story and wood and drywall
second story but this one is cinderblock
both stories
and also the doors open backwards the
door the front door opens outward and
like a damn trailer i'm like that's
really weird yeah and apparently but
newer houses they have that it's
hurricane standards
because they don't want your door
blowing in yeah so i guess all the new
houses that they're building you have to
build it like where the front door opens
uh outwardly open that way yeah it's as
odd as [ __ ] it is very weird yeah but
like when somebody because when somebody
like leaves a package i'm just kind of
like putting that it hits the package
and i open it and i was like that's very
strange i've never seen that before this
has got some high-end houses in it
where we at now
and um
the low-end houses are kind of like the
one we just left which they're still
pretty nice they're on bigger pieces of
land
we're in about the middle
the [ __ ] high-end ones are on this
lake that's out here i'm gonna get a
gopro for my motorcycle there's a big
lake i'm gonna make some videos so you
guys can ride with me and i'm gonna show
you everything all right i was going i
was riding around through the whole
thing and i'm going down by the lake and
i'm looking at the [ __ ] i'm looking
with envy at these [ __ ] in
their honky paradises
[ __ ] with these [ __ ] palaces and
[ __ ] dude had this like a nice two-story
[ __ ] house on the lake and parked
outside the garage was like a [ __ ]
1973 convertible [ __ ] cat uh maybe
1971 convertible cadillac totally
restored light blue
with the [ __ ]
top top was down and i'm going that
[ __ ] you know he's probably
listening to [ __ ] that [ __ ]
is probably listening to [ __ ]
bruce springsteen and [ __ ] driving
around on that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
how much you want to bet he's listening
to bruce springsteen yeah he was born to
run yeah yeah maybe we were born to run
i don't know that [ __ ]
mango says i pay 25 pounds a month for
internet and landline the internet
connection is high speed very good
upload speed also speaking of someone
who works in i.t the us does not have
great internet connection yeah i've
heard that ours is very very spotty and
very sporadic
yeah but but the challenge of bringing
internet to to the continental the
united states is selecting far outstrips
[ __ ] anything the uk is the size of
one of our [ __ ] smaller states we got
states that [ __ ] have fantastic
internet but go to mississippi and try
to find the internet that's like trying
to find internet in the amazon basin
it's going to be a huge net or that's
what i mean it's very spotty very spotty
and even somewhere like i said we're not
really out in the middle of nowhere
there's a lot of farms and stuff but if
you go like a mile or two up the road
there's like there's a publix there's a
chinese restaurant there's a sushi bar
there's all kind of stuff up there
there's like there's tons of [ __ ] up
there
we're not that far going on a couple of
miles and then you got everything you
got [ __ ] planet fitnesses and [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] like
um
it's a trip it's i lived in this same
neighborhood
just up the street
uh when i first moved here for a while
when i was working the [ __ ] the barn
circuit [ __ ]
after i left
louisiana and it was
pretty damn rural back then
it's not rural like it was anymore i
mean it's still rural but not it's as
rural as our old place was when we first
moved there about 10 years ago yeah see
it's
growing it's sprawling out we're on the
edge of it
but because
of the people that own a lot of this
land or farm owners and have these
[ __ ] gigantic
farms that are [ __ ] they're dealing
with in in animals and
million dollar animals and [ __ ]
it's always gonna this area will always
kind of be known for i think the animals
yeah it probably will and like i said
it's it's not like they're gonna develop
a lot of the land because a lot of the
land is farms like people own it and
and they grow [ __ ] on it and you keep
going and all of a sudden then there's
another city over there
you know it starts to build up yeah big
city we're actually not that far from
mount dorado yeah mount dora and mount
dora you got a lot of
the core of mount dora is like the
high-end new yorkers
that's kind of who owned that mount dora
is kind of known for being like a
antiques pub antiques and all artsy
fartsy [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
we're we're right by like mount dora and
uh sorrento yeah and you have like his
they have like a historic downtowns that
are [ __ ] hundreds of years old and
[ __ ] [ __ ] and
it's
restaurants and [ __ ] in there you know
small restaurants and marinas and crap
yeah mandy said mount dora is really
pretty though it is it is yeah it
actually almost looks a little bit like
new england yeah and i think it and a
lot of people that
live there also live in new york
and they this is kind of like their
vacation homes and stuff yeah we're
actually not that far from i was like
surprised when we went because we went
for a drive around here just to see what
was around and that that place near
where
that [ __ ]
drug lord mansion i was looking at
if you guys saw that stream
yeah i think that was like when i
thought we were gonna [ __ ] have to
leave and find a new place before i knew
they were gonna offer us this place
there was a [ __ ] drug lord mansion i
was looking at that was [ __ ] cheap
it was totally spanish it was it was
spanish architecture all made up with
mexican wood that came out of church it
had arches and [ __ ]
it was like it was so cool
i mean it was old it was a lot older
than this house yeah it was built in the
50s it was cool looking though yeah it
was built in the 50s you know it was all
[ __ ] brick and [ __ ]
and it looked like a spanish [ __ ]
castle and it did it looked like a
mission in there yeah
cool it was all 70s decor in the middle
in the size it looked like 70s carpeting
and everything it needed work you know i
mean it looked you could live in it but
it
that carpet man it was like some 70s
shag carpet it was turquoise yeah it was
like turkey yeah
it was some [ __ ] no not in all the
rooms i think it was it was nice tile at
on the bottom floor but on the top floor
it was like turquoise that looked like
[ __ ] ricardo monteblond's [ __ ] 70s
love man
[Laughter]
i would pip that [ __ ] out man it would
look gangster as [ __ ] that needs some
like that needs some like heart-shaped
beds in there i feel like
you know growing up in south american
[ __ ] is kind of bringing me back home
you know you see a lot of kind of
spanish-style architecture you know
which is normal for florida you know in
case you're dumb-ass you don't know this
was spanish territory
but it was uh purchased from spain after
the war of 1812. so
and
florida was always a mix of people
indians anglos and and people of the
spanish empire you know
and of course black people you know
they've just been here in in about the
same ratios forever
it's just the population was a lot
smaller back then
yeah florida is really interesting yeah
it's a crazy place it is a crazy place
and the further the further south you go
the less like
american america
or afro-america it is
and the less southern it is and the more
like
the more like nicaragua it becomes well
the thing about florida is that
the panhandle really like actually maybe
down into central florida is kind of
still the south because there's you
still have like pockets of like redneck
around yeah that's part of it but it's
kind of one of them yeah this is kind of
rednecky out here but in daytona's
rednecky like it's just like you know
and the panhandle is for sure like
really rednocky yeah but the farther
south you go the more like cuba it is
yeah or old cuba not modern yeah modern
cuba's [ __ ] up oh it doesn't have any
money imagine the way cuba should have
been
it's like cuba and then like with a big
ass swamp yeah in the middle of it i'd
probably put it on par with kind of like
it was kind of like um
kind of like [ __ ] uh
what's that
what's that country that [ __ ] got
taken over by the communists and
collapsed a lot of them moved here
same with the cubits uh
it's doing shitty now but it was doing
really good before all that happened
becca you don't know what i'm talking
about huh
you guys i can't not el salvador um
you guys don't know probably something
in the comment section we'll know which
sandra said now i picture you living in
the hills have eyes country no no it's
not like that like i said it's it's
mostly it's just far it's farms yeah
it's farms and like horse centers and
then there's like people's mansions and
stuff you guys if you got if anybody
wants to send me a gift for something
like a gopro something i could put onto
my my motorcycle helmet that has a
microphone on the inside
so i can record i'll [ __ ] put that
[ __ ] on my helmet and go out for a ride
and show you guys all kinds of i mean we
can do it in the car at some point like
i could just film it
i know but i mean i could film it with
my phone just so we could show what it
looks like
no
i kind of like
you know like i said i liked our old
neighborhood our old neighborhood was
nice too but the one thing that bothered
me about our old neighborhood was that
you know these are like you know three
four or five hundred dollar houses and
they were super close together
um you know which is for 500 houses
300 you know what i mean three or four
hundred thousand yeah yeah so but the
houses were kind of close together like
if the next door neighbor came out of
their driveway and talked i could hear
them you know what i'm saying um but
this neighborhood they really seem to
have
you know built the houses with like a
very significant uh space cushion
between
the houses which is actually really nice
so all the yards are like really really
really really big you can get a [ __ ]
really nice house out here for [ __ ]
two thousand dollars a month
two thousand dollars a month would you
that's what your mortgage would be
yeah it wouldn't be like that anywhere
else it would be a half a million dollar
home more or less
maybe less um than that
uh but it would be if that same house in
california would be like probably three
million
i would think yeah probably yeah
somebody asked if the cats had been
outside yet yeah beijing beijing escaped
yes
i'm starting to just let her out though
she walks around she's a grown lady
she's kind of like an old hat at it i'm
really i'm kind of nervous about letting
puke yeah i have not let pookie out
pookie actually hasn't she hasn't really
seemed all that interested um in going
outside at this new place she's
just kind of running around inside she's
mostly been just hanging out with us
hanging out with me in the office all
day um you know sleeping on the floor in
a chair or whatever dartmouth you're
right he nailed it the country i was
thinking was venezuela
yeah i thought that but i didn't say
yeah well i know because i thought i'd
be wrong and then you'd yell at me
no no venezuela uh matter of fact we
have a lot of venezuelans here and uh
who fled from that [ __ ] whole
catastrophe what's his name [ __ ]
anyway um and there was one i actually
knew one
he had a horse at one of the stables
that i was working at and uh barnes i
was working at and uh
he uh
he said that
he said that florida reminded him a lot
of venezuela that's why when in the good
days and that's why he moved here
and that's because the cubans did that
cuban americans are [ __ ] awesome
yeah it's a well like i said florida is
a very weird place that's why i kind of
feel like it doesn't usually get lumped
in with the south as much because it's
not exactly the same it is the south
parts of it are like the south but parts
of it are totally different it's just
that the south has [ __ ]
latin american
flavor to it and french
but in french too yeah you know
louisiana
is very french
uh it's
or it has holdovers of it you know i
mean because a lot of people migrate
into that area
mississippi had a french influence to it
also a real strong german influence in
mississippi um
same with alabama
it's just
a lot of a lot of people who live
outside the south get stereotypes about
the south coming to them
through hollywood
written by stories of by people who have
never been here or lived here don't
really know the culture or the
background or the history
um
it's an interesting place that i like it
and i've been all over the united states
and lived and even lived in new england
and everything
and uh central america and
went through europe and the middle east
the south is special man it's
it's got a lot of really good things for
going for it um
it's only really got one drawback if you
ask me it's [ __ ] hot humid
yeah i do not like that three or four
months out of the year it's [ __ ]
miserable
more than that uh as soon as it starts
getting into the 80s i can stay at it
see i'm i'm kind of more like uh 50s and
below
kind of person it's bad when it's in the
90s and 100s when it starts getting into
the 80s you still got 100 humidity it
still feels [ __ ] hot but you can
function in in it when it gets down into
the 70s it's nice
it's nice you'll still feel that
dappness in the air this is [ __ ]
dagobah
man some days even when i was growing up
and stuff like that like in the summer
you'd open the door to go outside and go
you know what [ __ ] it yeah you're like
[ __ ] it i'm going out
not today
because it's just like open and it was
like going into a wall it was like
yeah you know what i mean like it was a
solid it's like walking into a solid
back before air conditioning you had to
be a hard [ __ ] to live in the
south they were tough see i used to ask
my grandma about that all the time
because she moved down she moved down to
florida uh from tennessee in 1958
and they didn't have ac for a really
long time and um even later they just
had like a window unit like put into
their house later but i was like how did
you stand it like she's like i don't
know it just didn't bother me they
didn't know any dave they didn't i guess
she didn't know any different now
sometimes what they would do she said
now sometimes we would take like a box
fan and put it in the window and then
put like a bowl of ice cubes like in
front of it yeah
i mean i'm sure it was better than
nothing
but
i guess if i guess you just if you
didn't grow up with uh with air
conditioning you just kind of like got
used to it yeah
[Laughter]
well you're you would also adapt to it
yeah uh your standards of what hot is
and what your standards of what comfort
is would change a lot yeah you're just
like well i remember i'm just gonna have
swamp ass for six months yeah i remember
you know being a kid running around
mississippi in the south in the summer
all time you know [ __ ] when i'm you
know 10 you know seven five from eating
into my teens and i knew it was [ __ ]
hot and sweaty you know when you went
and came into a house like oh man it's
relief
but
i guess when you're just a kid or maybe
when you're just out of low iq or
something you just don't give a [ __ ]
well you're busy doing other stuff so
you're not really thinking about it yeah
and it was just part of it to be
drenched in sweat constantly and not and
kids are dirty they don't get yeah
kids are disgusting
for people who've never lived here when
it's hot and humid
you're you're constantly drenched in
sweat
but you're not sure because it's real
hard to sweat and humidity
well the sweating system that the body
has
has been subverted yeah because ideally
you're sw you're supposed to sweat and
the sweat's supposed to dry and cool you
off it doesn't work but it doesn't do
that it just you sweat and then it just
sits there
and it seals in even more moisture so
more of it comes out and it's like being
it's like being encased in plastic in
plastic yeah it's like yeah yeah it's
like being in case somebody because
because nothing can dry up because it's
too
the air is just so wet right that it's
just kind of like and like i said all of
your clothes you put on clothes
[Music]
honestly it's even after you take a
shower even in your air conditioned
house you take a shower you get out of
the shower you try to put on clothes and
your clothes are sticky like you cuz
you're still sticky even though it's air
conditioned in the house
i don't have that problem that much
maybe i do no that'll
close will kind of grip to you because
you're you're yeah you're always a
little kind of moist you're always kind
of moist yeah but it's not the kind of
moist yeah you always just kind of
you never really quite dry off
now
you get that ac really [ __ ] pumping
though i mean it gets so dry in there
that'll burn your nose
that's okay i'd rather have that
but um no that was kind of a new thing
when i was a kid running around here it
was window units the houses weren't
built with central air
yeah they didn't used to like i said my
grandmother's i grew up in a house with
just one window unit and the window my
unit might be in two rooms oh we just
had one in one room it was in the dining
room they were big back then they were
big they were expensive
but power was cheap because there
weren't that many people down here
so i don't know just i remember they
just they didn't give a [ __ ] about
[ __ ] power they'd run [ __ ] air
conditioner lights on all night and [ __ ]
like a bug zappers outside that didn't
do anything just zap [ __ ] bugs all
night
little pile of dead bugs underneath the
[ __ ] frogs eating them
that's it victor said my grandparents
said when they were kids they slept on
the covered porch sometimes yeah my
grandparents said they did that too like
sometimes slept outside so [ __ ] hot
because they had like a big carport and
it was like way up on a hill so you
couldn't really like see it
dermott said jenny i'm sure the welsh
weather suited you sometimes uh yeah i
liked that a lot actually
i didn't mind all the rain i didn't mind
actually the first year that i went
there which i think was 1995. uh they
had like the worst winter ever like that
they'd had in a really long time like it
snowed a lot and i was excited because
it was the first time i'd ever seen snow
but everybody else was like well they
all blamed me because they're like well
it doesn't usually snow this much but
because you wanted to see snow and then
you came and then it's like all the snow
they couldn't drive on the roads it was
like all [ __ ] blocked and stuff but i
was having a good time i was like snow
hooray i can pretend it's like [ __ ]
even though christmas is over it was in
january like i went in january but it's
like it really really snowed a lot i was
i was into it it was
colder than i was expecting like when i
first went there because like i said the
first time i went there it was january
and um when i landed at gatwick and i
was like waiting for the bus and i was
like wow it's
really damp and it's really really
freezing cold but i was like okay yes
you know i'd rather be cold like i said
when it's hot you can only take off so
many clothes
you know what i mean you're just like
laying there in a pair of underwear or
whatever it's like well i'm still hot
there's nothing else i can do but when
you're cold you can always put more
clothes on you know
uh yeah so
tammy says she also lives out in the
middle of nowhere so yeah you're feeling
the pain like i said it's not
i don't know it it's kind of in the
middle of nowhere but not there's stuff
that's not too far away like i said
there's a grocery store there's a
chinese place there's a dominoes
there's you know there's a dollar
general like within a mile or two which
is good
um
but i looked up a few things because i
was kind of like for example i was like
oh i need to get transparencies for the
screen printing where's the nearest
fedex office
and it's like 19 miles away you know
where's the closest movie theater it's
like 18 miles away so it's just kind of
like so it's little things like that
um
and then we were looking for something
the other day oh i was looking for uh we
were looking for more screen printing
[ __ ] like i need some photo emulsion
and i was like oh let's go to michael's
and the closest michael's is like 20
something miles away um there is a hobby
lobby but
um it was sunday and they're closed on
sunday because they're owned by
fundamentalists
so i was kind of like well that's not
gonna work so we had to go back to the
old house anyway so we just went to that
michael's but you know so there's little
things like that that are kind of like
far away and it's kind of a pain but
it's not really that much of a pain i
mean you know we can still get there
it's not it's not a huge deal
uh yeah dermot said i like the british
and irish weather it's what i was born
into so it doesn't bother me yeah see i
kind of i liked it i just you know i
know that i know it's kind of like
it's not here yet no i went down there
and went into the damn kitchen and
fought the urge for a few minutes to
[ __ ] make a drink
you can make one after a week i gotta
watch how to sit because my [ __ ] my junk
will [ __ ] fall out of the bottle
that big old [ __ ] mississippi white
snake would be [ __ ] hanging there
like oh my goodness that [ __ ] test
got me [ __ ] shoved out like a
[ __ ] constant chub
is that like a porn film is that maybe
too much information it's like
[ __ ] i'm gonna get paid
i'm gonna get paid that's just gonna go
straight [ __ ] only fan
guys lose a couple more pounds around
the waist and my [ __ ] only fan's
debut will begin
i'll [ __ ] put it down gopro on for
that
you can get images of me chasing jenny
around this [ __ ] he'll just have
a motorcycle helmet and the gopro and
then he'll just be naked otherwise it'll
just be like thrusting me running around
nothing but just a light coat of body
oil
and flip flops
you don't even have anything i know
crocs would be better yeah just
something tacky
just thinking of something tacky
flip-flop oh my god that's some type of
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
sandra's probably going to come up with
some names
[Laughter]
whenever a mississippi white snake yes
how does this [ __ ] happen oh my god it
just occurred to me that the band white
snake is probably named after of course
it is and you seen their debut album
no it's a nude woman [ __ ] wrestling
with a big old [ __ ] serpent that's
white and [ __ ] it's like a [ __ ]
statue
it's like i wasn't i i never really
thought about that waste much man
yeah now that now that you bring it up
i'm like oh yeah yeah i guess i didn't i
wasn't really into all that cockroach
back then yeah
so it didn't really like register
because i didn't really spend that much
time thinking about it
oh my god see women don't think about
the dick
[Laughter]
well why would we i'm looking at it i
feel like i feel like men are the only
ones that think about their dicks all
the time
the comments must be like [ __ ] two
minutes behind
i don't know my well yours are i don't i
don't think mine are okay
abel lopez says congrats on the move
thank you very much
that gives the name of gopro in all new
meanings
yeah i'm going pro
dj maniac says white snake is music for
old married couples
now it is yeah yeah i remember back in
the 80s when they first came out
uh because i think i was in junior high
i was in junior high of like first year
of high school
and i remember the certain type of
person that was into that kind of stuff
it was all that kind of like fat like
blonde feathered hair fringed denim
jacket type of
girls we're into that you know what i
mean yeah
bon jovi [ __ ] yeah it was like bon jovi
kind of stuff and which
which you know me like me and my couple
of friends that were like into goth and
new wave and stuff were just kind of
like we had no patience with that sandra
said todd did your sexy hat arrived yes
it did oh that's right i forgot about
your sexy he did but where is it it's
not finished i was gonna put like a
[ __ ] some festoon some [ __ ] i wanted
a big [ __ ] skull and crossbones or
something he's gonna look like a nazi
officer with that [ __ ] on well the thing
is that you can get you can get a
[ __ ] toten cough like a little
[ __ ] ss death head those are common
but nah
i would kind of more like just the
[ __ ] something that rob halfer would
have
wore you know what i mean yeah
there were one of the ones that i was
looking at was the war pig you know the
[ __ ] the thing from motorhead
oh yeah
yeah but the thing is it's kind of small
i wanted a small i wanted a bigger one
because you have to festoon the hat with
something it's a straight up [ __ ]
leather daddy hat it is you put that
[ __ ] on you're ready to suck some dick
sucking hat
that's what i said that's what you have
to officially call it
second hand yeah i mean you put that
[ __ ] on man [ __ ] you just the
gayetude the gay is i'm just [ __ ]
skyrocketing then your mouth will become
like a vacuum cleaner and all the dicks
in the vicinity will just go we'll just
be like you gotta stop them you gotta
stop them from coming at you man it's
yeah
well you know what i mean
my gay fans are gonna love this [ __ ]
though
everybody's asking where mirror spock is
we should bring him in here yeah put him
we should bring him and put him in front
of the put him in front of the bookcase
over there oh so okay i forgot them yeah
you go get the hat and go get mirror
spock i forgot to put it
i forgot to put him in here
mr roboto says uh when does one become
an old married couple officially
um i don't know i don't know if it's
necessarily like
if it's a time thing or if it's just
like a behavior thing you know what i'm
saying i've always thought that
like an old person
i've met some people younger than me
that i still considered like an old
person just because they acted like an
old person you know what i'm saying so
maybe it's kind of the same deal
thank you thank you april lopez number
one fan i like your little pair jumping
up and down oh my goodness
there he is
[Laughter]
don't block frankenstein
oh my god
he's like spock's like please don't
touch me there very uncomfortable
he's folding
yeah i forgot
because i forgot that he folded up and i
was like he's not going to fit in my car
but there you go yeah
all right scooch him oh yeah there you
go that's he can be in front of the
bookshelf because you can't really see
[Music]
oh my god
tila says yes
just like a g
there you go
look at that
look at that
i mean it doesn't look quite right with
the t-shirt but you know what i mean
[Laughter]
now he's pantomiming
[Laughter]
leather gloves and [ __ ]
i thought you had some yeah i got
somebody i don't have time to [ __ ]
dress up my leather daddy outfit yeah
that's true i'm gonna build a whole
[ __ ] rob halford style leather daddy
outfit i'll wear that [ __ ] to the club
yeah i know you well
you guys think i wouldn't [ __ ]
know the pants and [ __ ]
i want to wear leather though [ __ ]
because
it's too hot it's too hot and it doesn't
[ __ ] look right modern materials can
make that look a lot better putting
[ __ ] new rocks on or that i'll get
some motorcycle police pass with little
jobbers
make me a [ __ ] cop outfit sexual cop
sexual policeman
look at that show up and go wait hold on
hi i'm officer tom of the sexual police
what is that you got there
your papers please
okay
sheila said you look like a member of
the village people yeah
yeah well that was the idea kind of the
idea that was the idea german said tom
is auditioning for a remake of cruising
oh yeah yeah hell yeah
this you cannot get any gay or any more
masculine
i told you man you put this [ __ ] on and
[ __ ] dicks just start flying at you
when's that gonna happen i don't know
sure i don't know i guess i'm a little
disembodied i'm in a dick-free zone
that'd be funny if like a little
disembodied dick started like
the thing is the thing is about it is
that it's a medium it's a little loose
on me i'm thinking about actually
getting a small you have a tiny head
no
my head's medium
it's seven and a quarter no my head's
medium it's seven and a quarter man
that's my military size a seven and a
quarter i wonder how big my head is i
don't think i ever exactly
that should be medium
so it's a little i'm thinking about
maybe getting a size smaller but this
[ __ ] came from thailand this [ __ ] was
expensive it was 40 bucks and it's not
even real leather
it's pleather
pleather
[Laughter]
sex police was definitely a kids in the
hall skit yeah something
i kind of remember that i remember that
one and i remember the girl drank drunk
that was the funny thomas ross sexual
fascist
oh my god yeah there's another t-shirt
[Laughter]
i tell you what i'm telling you what's
going to happen to you
i'm telling you what i'm going to do to
you okay
i wish i had a smoking cigar i need a
big old cigar with this [ __ ]
would you like me to get you like a box
of cigars for christmas i think this
[ __ ] place it will yeah
and then you can't smoke him in the club
you got to get a [ __ ] vape cigar
i'll just vape on it
that would look stupid though
yeah
i had to have a [ __ ] big old [ __ ]
sam brown belt and instead of a pistol i
want in a holster i want a whip
can you have another holster on the
other side with a big dildo in it it'd
be like the [ __ ] holster
that won't be in the center though
yeah i feel like i feel like you
definitely need a cod piece now that
we're kind of like on the inside just
have that [ __ ] bulge out and then
[ __ ] wrap that [ __ ] around and make
it inflatable
[Laughter]
then it's just like bulging walk around
like nothing's happening walk around
like like what
it's just like a [ __ ] big old 40
ounce big
40 beer can coming around wrapping
around your leg oh my god then you put a
peach on the end of it
[Laughter]
and walk around like nothing happening
like it's like it's just normal well
just well yeah you have to walk around
like it's just like your everyday [ __ ]
yeah because if you kind of walk around
can't cause attention to it then then
the cool factor goes away well then
everybody will know it's fake they know
that [ __ ] is fake you know you just sit
down and move it
[Laughter]
it's like i can't even cross my legs god
damn it
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure you can get a dildo
cigar
yeah i think you can get a dildo shaped
like pretty much anything
one of my favorite things when i was
back when i had like um a little online
sex toy shop was uh the jesus butt plug
yeah uh that was fun
so
i sold a couple of those
look how spooky
it's like you're here but yeah what's
funny is that the comments are talking
about it like i'm here
your ass is way behind yeah it's it's
just the uh it's just my mobile device i
gotta have this i'm gonna take this [ __ ]
in there and get it [ __ ]
get it worked on
that means you need to be tuned up yeah
you need to listen it's probably
bringing that [ __ ] maybe maybe it's
because we moved out here
yeah maybe i mean i don't i don't know i
don't know like i said um you know
jenny you sold jesus buttplugs
well that was one of the things
there's just stuff it was all kind of
stuff all kind of we had a store at one
time it was an online store sold all
kinds of uh
[ __ ] sex toys and [ __ ] but it was all
drop shipping we never really saw the
product yeah some of the best sellers i
think i brought this up before
were sounding kits because yeah that's a
lot of people had those and um
those weird like disembodied sex toys
for men which were just like an ass
and a vagina
you know what i'm saying and i was just
like i thought that was so weird
i don't i don't know i guess it's not
that weird tina all chaps are assless
yeah she's saying where's the ashley's
chat
chaps are assless if they didn't if they
didn't have if they had an ass they'd
just be pants yeah yeah
tila also said you needed a studded
collar and a leash uh i got i got
[ __ ] pickle thick
collars and [ __ ] um they're not studded
they were actually i don't have that one
anymore
that's kind of out that's tacky [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ]
what i would do with this hat is you
have to make a [ __ ]
a dominator outfit basically you're a
[ __ ] you're a sexual cop sexual
policeman
okay
and and you're slightly you're fascist
too you're almost kind of like
part of the sex ss
it's got to have that proud member of
the sex sss it's got to have a teutonic
flair to it
[Laughter]
it's like
touch my monkey
stop it
touch it love it stop you're spoiling
him
that's a blast from the past
sprockets
uh yeah elsa said did you just buy the
sex toys wholesale and shipped them out
on amazon yeah it was we had like a drop
shipping service yeah um so like i said
we didn't keep any inventory just like
when somebody ordered it we just ordered
it from the wholesaler and that was just
the early days that was the early days
of youtube not youtube uh what do you
call it uh
it was just really interesting
people watch it
i found it interesting anyway
i was surprised at how many people
bought sounding kits i didn't know that
that was that i mean it wasn't because
people didn't have a stop people most
people didn't keep carry them yeah
because it's more of like a specialty
item i mean you know everybody's got
like [ __ ] dildos and [ __ ] like that
that's like pretty easy to get i think
even [ __ ] man i think if well if you
have a mall that still has stuff in it
uh i think they even started selling
dildos and [ __ ] at [ __ ] spencer gifts
so you go to the mall and get a [ __ ]
dildo nowadays or vibrators so it's not
really that if you go in the back how
long have been streaming
uh hour and a half where is that damn
ups and it looks like the stream is
still holding for most people nobody's
complaining so that's actually a pretty
good sign yeah like i said maybe if i
you know scooch down the resolution more
yeah
then maybe we can do it without it
glitching out but nobody said anything
about the audio so the audio still seems
to be and like i said i haven't my [ __ ]
hasn't frozen up on this end which is a
problem that we were having on the old
laptop at the old house
because remember that because we do have
like um seriously the the modem is right
there we put the modem right here i said
put that right on my [ __ ] desk yeah
you you got a wire and i have the lan
cable it's like hooked right to it so i
wanted it as close to this [ __ ]
laptop as possible
um just but the satellite dish is
right out there like right down the hall
so out the window
um yeah tila says uh fyi i'm on amazon
right now and checking out all the adult
sensual toys and games pretty cool
prices
yeah they have a lot of stuff on there
but you know what what ended up
happening was that i think like some
bigger sellers
kind of took over and like a lot of the
smaller sellers kind of got pushed out i
guess
because that was kind of all i was
selling on there
and then you know that's how that
happened
uh yeah dermott said the audio is
crystal clear yeah everybody said like
the audio didn't isn't glitching
just the pictures drop the resolution a
bit yeah i'd probably keep the frame
rate the same see if it worked yeah so
hopefully if i just do that then maybe
it'll be okay like i said it might be a
little blurry but put it down to like
320 or 420 something like that but
what's it called four four yeah so i
think it's four eighty is it four eighty
you're at what seven something 720 yeah
that's way high
that's sd that's that's that's
like standard definition yeah
well we'll try that for the friday show
because like i said this was just
sidetracks and this is kind of like an
experiment
and you know we were kind of like scared
to do it we could always you know do a
spur of the moment stream they don't
have to be you know if we wanted to do a
test we could always just do a test and
[ __ ] around they could get a free
[ __ ] yeah like i said we were
actually gonna do a test yesterday we
just didn't get around to it because we
were so busy and we got people in other
time zones that are never able to catch
us live that's true so you know i mean
if we came in here in the morning and
[ __ ] around for a couple hours we
could probably pick up some people that
never get to see us that's true so i'm
not worried about this on time [ __ ] all
the time you know what i mean we could
have an on time show but then you could
also
[ __ ] around
i can make i could i can make [ __ ] up
[ __ ] anytime
well yeah you're good at that you know
what i mean i like to perform live and
[ __ ]
and uh clown around and [ __ ] freaking
if something's going on i'll [ __ ]
include the audience you know
[Laughter]
mr roboto says things you can put jesus
on
uh fun fact i actually have a thing
right over there i don't remember where
i put it but i think it's like right on
that uh which oh i went blurry because i
moved yeah i think it's right over there
on that uh on that shelf i have a thing
that puts an image of jesus on your
toast like you push it into the bread
and then you put the bread in the
toaster and then it comes out and then
there's jesus is on your toast isn't
that neat it looks super cool too
so i kept thinking maybe i'll like open
up a business on ebay like selling jesus
toast like i'll put it in little [ __ ]
because it looks pretty cool but they'd
all kind of look the same you know but
yeah so
tom live in concert yeah
[Laughter]
graham has seen it i think we were in
the same shows together weren't we
graham
yeah probably probably
yeah you really do seem to
uh i'm glad you came back for this one
because i was just kind of like i was i
i don't mind streaming by myself i don't
mind recording by myself but it's not as
fun
because it's like you know i can
interact with you guys but it's like
it's a lot more fun when you're here to
like say crazy [ __ ] that
you know what i mean
we still have to do we still have to do
a recording too you know that man yeah
well then maybe we should stop stream
i mean well we gotta sort these shirts
out
if they ever show up right now if the
tank tops don't know i'm done down there
right i gotta go back tomorrow i know i
got it but tomorrow we don't have as
much stuff to do i got to do drywall and
i got to finish [ __ ] i mean we don't
have as much stuff to do here right
i'm free to go do that more yeah but
like i said we need to do a recording
right you need to respect as well you
respect my projects well you need to
respect my projects also
and i told you earlier that we had to
record [ __ ] there man my ass is on the
line with that [ __ ] well i don't want to
start paying security deposits
but you got well i mean you got a lot
done today though because you sent me
the picture of the cabinet that house
got a pass mustard man yeah
that the landlord is moving into that
house that shit's got to be [ __ ]
right
yeah okay
but like i said you know you were there
all day today and you can go back
tomorrow but like i said we just have to
do the sh we have to finish the shirts
if okay if those tank tops
do not show up
by seven o'clock then we'll just take
the shirts that we have which is most of
them and i'll just say you know i'll
i'll either send them the tank tops like
i'll overnight it or i'll just
get it delivered again or i'll just send
them
you know tomorrow or whatever like
whenever i can get them done because we
can't wait it's 6 30.
um so we gotta so but like i said if
they haven't come by seven we can do a
recording we'll take them the shirts
because it won't take us that long to
get to altamonte springs right
no
um it's only 17 shirts
yeah
all the regular shirts are done like i
said it's only the tank tops because
only the blank tank tops got delayed
because i could coming from i could push
back delivery
and if if they come later than that when
we're
streaming we'll [ __ ] when we're doing
that show
we'll execute that shirt we'll
we'll finish that order yeah we'll get
it done that's every [ __ ] screen i
have there's no time to clean them just
i'm gonna throw them in the swimming
into into the [ __ ] tub into the tub
yeah
pull put water in the tub and i'm down
the screen just throw the tub yeah move
on grab the next screen no time to clean
in between images
yeah we'll just like i said we'll just
knock them out it's not really it's not
that many i mean we did we already did
well the total was 81 shirts so we did
all but 17 of them because 17 were tank
tops and we didn't get those we just got
the regular shirts when you see 81
shirts man that's
a lot huge and it's honestly it's not
the printing that takes a long time it's
the drying because you have to dry them
individually with a heat gun or an iron
for a certain amount of time so it's
like you know there's like a thing of
like 30 40 50 shirts and you're sitting
there going
with the heat gun or the iron and it
takes forever
yeah and i got people asking for new
designs we have the designs but i have
to execute those too yeah once this
batch is done we're going to come up
with some new designs ocp is going to be
one of them which is from robocop
uh there was a couple of other ones
i think i have we had written down or we
did them didn't we yeah yeah i have the
designs i just haven't done the
transparency there's a couple of other
ones and then they're gonna be themed
shirts
yeah
phil says you guys make me laugh i
really needed the show oh that's good
i'm glad it actually worked out even
though like i said i'm sorry about it
being glitchy and everything but we'll
like we'll work it all out this is the
first time we've been streaming with
this internet service so we didn't
really know what to expect uh mr robot
has said are you two fully moved in is
pookie and beijing all comfy they seem
to have adapted uh they're running up
and down the stairs they're farting
around the house um
beijing escaped outside but she came
back in she i guess she just wanted to
run around the house pookie doesn't
really seem to care about going outside
she's mostly been staying up here she
goes downstairs and plays sometimes but
she's mostly been staying up here and
hanging out in my office most of the day
um but yeah moving is a beast says camp
guy but it helps to clean everything out
and get rid of a bunch of junk that was
actually what was nice because i ended
up throwing out like so much stuff and
we threw out like a bunch of
furniture we weren't using that was kind
of broken i threw out a bunch of [ __ ]
that was up in the attic and it's like a
bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] that i don't even
know why i still had it like from the
last place i moved that i just i guess i
didn't even look at it i was just kind
of like i'm just going to keep it in
there and throw it up in the attic but
yeah i threw a bunch of it out
uh yeah camp guy said not glitchy much
on this end nothing more than just a few
seconds once or twice over this whole
time we'll see that's good um but like i
said i'll probably like scooch down the
resolution for the friday show friday's
show is going to be about
elliot roger and yeah and the incels
another thing is is that um
scooching it scooching that graphics
down would probably help because the
streams will be longer
yeah
and we got to stop this five hour
[ __ ] show [ __ ] i think i think we're
actually losing people
having that [ __ ] well not a lot of
people have like five hours free to just
kind of like sit around yeah although
sometimes we're just having a good time
so i'd like to try to keep these shows
around two hours
the main show well we'll see i think if
it goes over i think we're actually
[ __ ] driving some people away like i
ain't sitting around [ __ ] three hours
that's true i mean there's some channels
i could listen to all day
but you know what i mean success is a
[ __ ] numbers game too you know
that's true
what oh no i thought that oh i thought
that was the chair cheers the chair
squeaked and it sounded just like pookie
going hey
i thought she was back there like going
like that well it's not my ass we could
[Laughter]
very well although it might be better if
your ass does squeak
it's not speaking it might be too loose
right
like how'd that [ __ ] get loose yeah
people might be thinking
with the hat like that what the [ __ ]
were you doing to get that ass loose
damn i didn't think of that that's how i
got
as a as
a as a
as a neo-sexual fascist
i have to [ __ ] keep keep track of
what i'm saying and and and keep gender
straight
about it
yeah you know
because you have to you have to remain
male at all times hyper masculinity at
all times
okay
you can't say anything or do anything
that could be construed as a feminist so
you can't say anything that would imply
that you have a loose butthole exactly
gotcha
you better if you didn't even have one
kind of like kim jong-il
the north korean leaders they don't have
[ __ ] they even go to the bathroom
according to according to them
everything just stays all the poops in
there until they magical process they're
just magical living beings they don't
have metabolism
i wish i didn't have metabolism yeah dj
maniac says no tom i need the long shows
for my days at work yeah elsa says oh i
love the five hour shows
see
[ __ ] backed by popular demands camp guy
this show reminds me of just hanging out
the pub with my buds
uh and elsa said yeah i can always watch
the rest of the show later
yeah and mega says now five hours is
cool
well i know that you know the crowd that
we have likes those long shows maybe
that's why we have the crowd that we
have well because it's kind of like well
sometimes like when i was like
straightening up the office like i would
put on
you know a channel that i like and then
that you know they'd have hour
hour and a half long videos and i just
put a bunch of them in a playlist so i
had something to listen to while i was
so i think that's what people are doing
with our show they're just like listen
to us while they're doing other [ __ ]
because i do that
i do that too
sandra says two hours is impossible we
already need 30 minutes to warm up
i know and we didn't even get like i
only had one drink uh and tom didn't
really have any he just had a sip of
mine because like i said we still have
to do those shirts and i haven't eaten
today take them somewhere i had a piece
of toast
like at nine o'clock this morning and
that's that was um a long time ago i'll
just inject some more testosterone
i don't know maybe we can get crazy
i know it's wednesday wednesday maybe we
can get something to eat while we're out
dropping the shirts off yeah but like i
said the ups guys the shirts off right
across there from burger king
yeah okay
[Laughter]
what else is out there where do you want
to go that's true well yeah that yeah
there's a bk right there burger king
right there that's true like right next
to the starbucks
you know carrot carryout [ __ ]
chinese um
no burger king is okay chinese buffet
i want it to be a clean high protein
meal though
no fries or nothing you know what i mean
just me yeah we can meet me he could i
could we could [ __ ] swing
swing out towards koi wan
student support services says uh over my
dead body will you shorten this show i'm
painting a room right now and need my
five hours
it can't be five hours tonight man we're
gonna have to jump off here in a bit
what time is it it is 6 41. like i said
ups guy has 20 damn minutes 20 minutes
to get here they said that the shirts
would be here before seven o'clock today
that's what they said
is that them no i don't see anything let
me go check all day long it's like every
time like i heard a motor go by i leave
my on-screen fashion
okay
you guys should order out yeah there's
like there's a dominoes not far from us
there's a chinese place which actually
because you know
we didn't really feel like cook like we
didn't know where anything was in the
kitchen and like some of the food was at
the old house and [ __ ] like that so
we've been eating out a lot there's a
publix up the street so we would just be
getting [ __ ] from the publix deli
there's a chinese place up there which
is actually pretty decent we got some uh
he got some general sews and i got some
[ __ ] what the hell did i get i don't
know shrimp and mixed vegetables or
shrimp looming or something like that
and that was actually really good and
there's something else down there too
there's like a
there's like a breakfast place like a or
a brunch place they close at two o'clock
though um so i don't know if that's any
good and then there's like a sushi bar
restaurant and i think they have like a
big bar as well so that's right up the
street and like i said there's a
dominoes so if we had to order pizza we
could
but so like i said it's we're not out in
the middle of nowhere but not here not
yet
like i said if if the ups isn't here
till seven then i'm assuming
isn't here before seven
then i'm assuming that it probably won't
be here till tomorrow which means that
we should probably just take the shirts
that we have yeah so they have something
to go with it's on them man they didn't
give me any time to [ __ ] get this
order done correct and like i said
they're lucky they got the [ __ ] as good
as they got and the numbers that they
got yeah there's just no time there
wasn't any time to correct if there was
any major problems we would have been
able to correct them yeah but like lucky
didn't make any mistakes yeah well
that's what i mean i was just like well
we have to get this right the first time
so try not to like rush through it
because we did man with like the last
two days been long days like the [ __ ]
all the shirts and because it's four i
mean it was a front and a back on it was
two different shirts but they both had a
front and back so it was four different
screens so you had to do all the fronts
and then dry all of that and then do all
the backs and dry all of those and
usually a big order especially if it's a
new image it never goes right uh
something always goes wrong
and we had something go wrong on this
one
but it was able to save it remember yeah
that one screen blew out yeah i had to
reshoot that one yep
yep and
but that was a minor one world of screen
printing we didn't even misprint
anything
yeah usually we'll misprint something
you got you got to wash the shirt i
can't believe that we gotta wash your
shirt i can't believe that you're dry
you gotta come back we didn't mess
anything up
[Laughter]
oh my god all right so
should we
all right so i know this has only been
like almost two hours but
just cut this one this will record that
[ __ ] that you need to record for this no
waffle house nearby actually there's a
waffle house it's probably about three
or four miles from here they got greasy
spoons here yeah where you can go
remember that breakfast place yeah that
was out there
well there's a breakfast place like i
said like right up there by the publix
there's also a real mexican um market
with a restaurant in there i went in
there and ate if i'd had to go yeah
we've eaten there before i had to go pro
i showed you guys what it did man it was
pretty good i had
i had um gorgitas
alpa store
really good they're
yeah that's actually not a bad
restaurant it's like a piece of
cornbread kinda
like a cornbread kind of
slit three of them with marinated pork
and then
all kinds of toppings in there man it
was [ __ ] really good really good
and i was like the only white guy in
there man only person speaking english
yeah it's all mexicans and central
americans in there and they're all the
work crews it's right across the street
from that biker bar i'll show it to you
guys i'll take a video in there yeah you
need to get it going the food's [ __ ]
good man real good it is really good
i ordered a side of guacamole
and when it came it came on those little
stone things with the [ __ ] lot with a
little [ __ ]
look like volcanic rock with a little
[ __ ] feet on it like a little
cauldron yeah yeah it looked like it was
plastic though i checked this is
and it was fresh avocado and cilantro
with onions and tomatoes and i don't
even think there was any garlic in it it
was just kind of
chopped up real finely and slightly
stirred man that [ __ ] was so good yeah
yeah they make their own tortillas make
their own tortilla chips
make their own tortillas you know they
flour and corn that's good i don't know
if they make the flour they're making a
corn you can't buy that corn
all right so we will see you guys again
on friday night for our regular stream
hopefully it will be less glitchy than
this one but i'm glad that this one went
as well as could be expected
without anything like crashing a lot
better than i thought it was going to be
i thought it was going to suck i thought
this was going to crash
because when i i checked the speed and
it was only one megabyte
one megabyte a second one like i said
it didn't it didn't drop the stream it's
just glitchy that's all and like i said
maybe if i you know do the resolution
down it should be okay so we'll be back
friday night like i said we're doing a
show about elliot roger
and the incel movement so that should be
a good one i've actually been looking
forward to doing that show
because that's going to be like a lot of
fun to pick on those dudes but uh yeah
so thank you everybody for dropping by
so lovely to see you guys again we
missed you guys and this was really fun
so now we gotta go do some more work for
the rest of the evening so
have a good rest of your night you guys
and we will see you on friday
bye